-Performing a medley
of the songs
"Wonderful"
and "Monsters You Made,"
from his new album,
"Twice as Tall," out now,
here is Burna Boy.
-♪♪ Anywhere I go
mo n' lati pada si ile mi
-♪♪ 'Cause mama
mi won wa ni ile mi ♪♪
-♪♪ I no want make person
tell me say I too lazy ♪♪
-♪♪ Oluwaburna of la la ni
-♪♪ As I dey hustle
like Adebayor Ogunlesi ♪♪
-♪♪ No go talk,
say me I too lazy ♪♪
-♪♪ Anywhere I go
mo n' lati pada si ile mi
-♪♪ 'Cause mama
mi won wa ni ile mi ♪♪
♪♪♪♪
♪♪ Wonderful ♪♪
♪♪ Ah ♪♪
♪♪ I go show you wonder
waa ri wonderful ♪♪
♪♪ You no go believe
wetin won happen ♪♪
♪♪ No disturbance
when the gbedu wan catch you ♪
♪♪ Like you dey sleep
but this one pass you ♪♪
♪♪♪♪
♪♪ As the gbedu don start,
won jo ♪♪
♪♪ From your feet all over
♪♪♪♪
♪♪ With somebody daughter,
won jo ♪♪
♪♪ 'Cause I'm feeling it
in my soul ♪♪
♪♪ Something is changing ♪♪
♪♪ Right in your face,
yeah, yeah ♪♪
♪♪ Slow ♪♪
♪♪ Something dey scratch me
♪♪ Kon be like jazz ♪♪
♪♪♪♪
♪♪ Anywhere I go
mo n' lati pada si ile mi
♪♪ 'Cause mama
mi won wa ni ile mi ♪♪
♪♪ I no want make person tell
say I too lazy ♪♪
♪♪ Oluwaburna of la la ni
♪♪ As I dey hustle
like Adebayor Ogunlesi ♪♪
♪♪ No go talk say me I too lazy
♪♪ Anywhere I go
mo n' lati pada si ile mi
♪♪ 'Cause mama
mi won wa ni ile mi ♪♪♪♪
♪♪♪♪
♪♪ Calling me a monster,
calling us fake ♪♪
♪♪ No way, no way, no way
♪♪ Calling me a monster
just 'cause we safe ♪♪
♪♪♪♪
♪♪ Welcome where it rains
♪♪ Where we create barricades
♪♪ Keep our positional weight
♪♪ That's why we strap
with the case ♪♪
♪♪ Don't get up
from your place ♪♪
♪♪ 'Cause it could happen today
♪♪ Not knowing how to behave
♪♪ That is a sign that you make
♪♪ Just loose your life,
what a waste ♪♪
♪♪ Your body found in a lake
♪♪ You...around in the fish
♪♪ Man found you drownin'
for days ♪♪
♪♪ You know we come
from a place ♪♪
♪♪ Where people smile
but it's fake ♪♪
♪♪ How could they smile
if you look around me ♪♪
♪♪ Surrounded by paint ♪♪
♪♪ I seen the sky turn to grey
♪♪ It took the light
from the day ♪♪
♪♪ It's like
their heads of the state ♪
♪♪ Ain't comprehending the hate
♪♪ That the oppressed generate
♪♪ When they been
working like slaves ♪♪
♪♪ To get some minimum wage
♪♪ You turn around
and you blame them ♪♪
♪♪ The heck of enrage ♪♪
♪♪ Put them
in shackles and chains ♪♪
♪♪ Because of what they became
♪♪ We are the monsters you made
♪♪ Calling me a monster,
calling us fake ♪♪
♪♪ No way, no way, no way
♪♪ Calling me a monster
just 'cause we safe ♪♪
♪♪♪♪
♪♪ No way, no way, no way
♪♪ Calling me a monster,
make no mistake ♪♪
♪♪ That there's only
so much that you can take
♪♪ We are the monsters you made
♪♪ We are the monsters
you made ♪♪